ANSWERS BUT FIRST, WHAT THEY ARE
NOT TELLING YOU.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
LAST NIGHT WE EXPOSED THE LIES
AND THE FEARMONGERING USED TO
JUSTIFY CLOSING SCHOOLS ACROSS
AMERICA.
WE SHOWED THE BEST SCIENCE OUT
THERE MAKE AND WHY OLD-SCHOOL
COMMOTION SCHOOLS TO REOPEN WITH
THEIR STUDENTS PREFERABLY FIVE
DAYS A WEEK.
THE RESPONSE I HAVE TO SAY WAS
HUGE AND BIPARTISAN.
CHILDREN MUST BE TAUGHT IN
PERSON.
NEVERTHELESS LEGAL KENTUCKY JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT ALL FALL CLASSES
WILL BE ONLINE.
SAME WITH SAN FRANCISCO’S
SCHOOLS.
NO FORGET THE EXTENSIVE NEW
GERMAN STUDY SHOWING THAT KIDS
CAN’T READILY SPREAD THE VIRUS
WHERE THAT SCHOOLS ACROSS EUROPE
HAVE NOT SEEN ANY MAJOR SPREAD
SINCE THE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
OPEN.
CAN’T LET THE FACTS GET IN THE
WAY OF SPREADING PANIC.
AS FAR AS THE MEDIA
HYPERVENTILATION ABOUT RISING
HOSPITAL NUMBERS, REMEMBER, THIS
IS CHEAPLY TIED TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN FOUR STATES,
FLORIDA, CALIFORNIA, TEXAS,
ARIZONA WHERE NUMBERS DID
INCREASE AFTER A PERFECT STORM
OF REOPENING, PROTEST, RIOTS AND
TRAVEL FROM SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
NOW, BY THE WAY EVEN IN ARIZONA,
THE ROLLING NUMBER OF CONFIRMED
CASES IS ALREADY LOWER COMPARED
TO WHEN WE COULD GO.
THAT IS GOOD NEWS.
WE HOPE IT CONTINUES.
BUT NOW WE TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF MASK MANDATES.
>> WE SEEN WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN
PEOPLE COME TOGETHER WITH FACE
COVERINGS.
>> WE WON’T GIVE PEOPLE MORE TO
SHOP SAFELY AND IN HOUSE
PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE WHO WORK
IN SHOPS.
BOTH OF THESE CAN BE DONE BY THE
USE OF FACE COVERINGS.
>> YOU CAN LITERALLY KILL
SOMEONE BECAUSE YOU DIDN’T WANT
TO WEAR A MASK.
>> THE BENEFIT OF WEARING A MASK
CLEARLY IS THEY ARE MET.
>> NOW I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR, I’M
NOT TELLING ANYONE NOT TO WEAR A
MASK.
THAT IS NOT WHAT WE ARE HERE
FOR.
INSTEAD I WANT TO MOVE BEHIND
HER PER BELIEF AND WHAT THE
LATEST SCIENCE ACTUALLY TELLS
US.
WE HAVE HEARD FOR MONTHS THAT
WEARING FACE COVERINGS EVEN
HOMEMADE ONES IS SELFLESS THING
TO DO AND EVEN A PATRIOTIC DUTY,
WHICH I HAVE TO SAY SOUNDS
PRETTY COOL AND EVEN SOUNDS LIKE
A UNIFYING THING.
THE EMOTIONAL ARGUMENT IS REALLY
WONDERFUL, BUT AGAIN, WHAT ABOUT
THE ACTUAL DATA?
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING FROM THE
VERY MEDICAL JOURNAL AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE LED TO
BELIEVE ARE INFALLIBLE.
82015 STUDY RECRUITED
HEALTH CARE WORKERS FROM
HOSPITALS FROM VIETNAM, AND
EXAMINED THE BENEFITS OF CLOTH
MASK IN A HEALTH CARE
SETTING AND MEASURED FLU AND
FLU-LIKE TRANSMISSION.
WELL, THE RESULTS MAY SURPRISE
YOU.
THE RATES OF ALL INFECTION
OUTCOMES WERE HIGHEST IN THE
CLOTH MASK ARM PENETRATION OF
CLOTH MASK PARTICLES WAS ALMOST
95% AND MEDICAL MASKS, 44%.
NOW THIS IS A RANDOMIZED
CONTROLLED TRIAL OF MORE THAN
1600 HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND HAD
THIS DONE IN CONCLUSION.
THE RESULTS CAUTIONED AGAINST
THE USE OF CLOTH MASKS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FINDING TO
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH & SAFETY.
MOISTURE ATTENTION, REUSE OF
CLOTH MASKS AND INFILTRATION MAY
RESULT IN INCREASED RISK OF
INFECTION.
OKAY.
WELL, WHAT ABOUT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION?
I’M SURE THEY RECOMMEND MASKS.
WELL, JUST GO TO THE W.H.O.
WEBSITE WHERE THEY SAY THEY HAVE
LIMITED EVIDENCE BY HEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS AND HOUSEHOLDS IN
PARTICULAR, THOSE WHO SHARE A
HOUSE WITH A SICK PERSON OR
ATTENDEES OF MASK GATHERINGS MAY
BE BENEFICIAL AS A MEASURE OF
PREVENTING THE TRANSMISSION.
AT PRESENT, THERE IS NO DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE UNIVERSAL MASKING OF HEALTHY
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY TO
PREVENT INFECTION WITH
RESPIRATORY VIRUSES, INCLUDING
COVID-19.
THEN THERE IS THE GOLD STANDARD
ITSELF, THE CDC.
BACK IN JANUARY, IT RECOMMENDED
AGAINST MASTS AND DR. FAUCHER
REPEATED THAT GUIDANCE IN MARCH.
>> THERE IS NO REASON TO BE
WALKING AROUND WITH A MASK.
WHEN YOU WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
AN OUTBREAK, WEARING A MASK
MIGHT MAKE PEOPLE FEEL A LITTLE
BIT BETTER, AND IT MIGHT EVEN
BLOCK A DROPLET, BUT IT’S NOT
PROVIDING THE PERFECT PROTECTION
THAT PEOPLE THINK IT IS.
>> Laura: NOW, HE EXPLAINED
HIS MASK FLIP AND HE’S IN FAVOR
OF THEM SAYING THOSE COMMENTS
INITIALLY MOTIVATED FOR CONCERN
FOR SAVING MASKS FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS.
FACEBOOK, BY THE WAY, NOW FLAGS
THE OLD INTERVIEW WITH DR. FELTY
AS FALSE INFORMATION.
BUT HE SURE SEEMED CONVINCING.
BUT THAT IS NOT ALL, IN APRIL
STUDY SEEMS CONSISTENT WITH THE
OLD DR. FAUCI HAS WELCOME OF
VIRAL SHEDDING THE COUGHING OF A
HUNDRED AND 11 PARTICIPANTS,
SOME WEARING MASKS, SOME NOT,
THE RESULTS AMONG THE SAMPLE
COLLECTED WITHOUT A FACE MASK,
WE FOUND THE MAJORITY OF
PARTICIPANTS WITH INFLUENZA
VIRUS AND CORONAVIRUS INFECTION
DID NOT SHED DETECTABLE VIRUS IN
RESPIRATORY DROPLETS OR AEROSOL.
FOR THOSE WHO DID SHED VIRUS IN
RESPIRATORY DROPLETS AND
AEROSOL, VIRAL LOADED IN BOTH
TENDED TO BE LOW.
WAIT, WHAT?
THE MAJORITY OF CONFIRMED
CORONAVIRUS INFECTIONS WITHOUT A
FACE MASK DIDN’T SHED DETECTABLE
VIRUS IN RESPIRATORY DROPLETS OR
AEROSOL?
AND TO THOSE WHO ACTUALLY DID
THE MINORITY, THERE WAS VERY
LITTLE VIRUS PRESENTS?
OKAY, WAIT, IT GETS BETTER.
THE MAJOR LIMITATION OF THE
STUDY WAS THE LARGE PROPORTION
OF PARTICIPANTS WITH
UNDETECTABLE VIRAL SHEDDING AND
EXHALED BREATH IN EACH OF THE
VIRUSES STUDIED.
WE COULD HAVE INCREASED THE
SAMPLING DURATION BEYOND
30 MINUTES TO INCREASE THE VIRAL
SHEDDING BEING CAPTURED BUT
APPARENTLY PEOPLE DIDN’T WANT TO
DO THAT.
SO AGAIN, LET ME EXPLAIN THIS
OVER THE THIS BASE HAVE
30 MINUTES, THEY WERE UNABLE TO
CAPTURE ANY VIRAL SHEDDING IN A
LARGE PROPORTION OF PARTICIPANTS
WITH CONFIRMED KNOWN INFECTIONS.
AGAIN, WHAT?
INDEED.
THEY GO ON TO EXPLAIN THAT
PERHAPS FORCED COUGHING, FORCED
COUGHING MIGHT HAVE HELPED.
FORCED COUGHING?
SO THE ISSUE AS EXPLAINED IN
THIS STUDY IS THAT NONCOUGHING
OR SNEEZING PEOPLE ARE BY AND
LARGE NOT SHEDDING VIRUS IN
THEIR ORDINARY BREATH.
IT IS IF THEY ARE COUGHING FROM
A COURSE FROM A DIFFERENT STORY
OF COURSE.
SOMEONE WHO IS ACTIVELY SICK,
WELL THEY ARE ACTIVELY SICK.
BUT ESPECIALLY NOW.
MANY CORONAVIRUS INFECTIONS ARE
NOT SYMPTOMATIC FOR COSTS AND
AMONG THOSE ACTIVELY SICK BUT
NOT COUGHING, THEY HAD GREAT
DIFFICULTY IN THE STUDY FINDING
VIRUS EXPELLED UNDER LAB
CONDITIONS.
AND IN LAB CONDITIONS, EXTREMELY
SENSITIVE EQUIPMENT.
AGAIN, THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE
ACTIVELY SICK AND HAD A FEVER.
SO, SO MUCH FOR THE THEORY OF
ASYMPTOMATIC SHEDDING OF
INFECTIOUS VIRUS OUT OF ONE’S
MOUTH OR NOSE.
BY THE WAY, THE ENTIRE PREMISE
ON WHICH THE MASK MANDATES ARE
PREDICATED.
DO YOU SEE OR SMELL OR HEAR A
PROBLEM HERE?
THERE IS CONFLICTING INFORMATION
INFORMATION, SCIENTIFIC FIND
FINDINGS, UNMASKED ON KIDS?
IT IS HARD TO SEE HOW ANY OF
THAT SHOULD BE THE NEW NORMAL
GIVEN REPORTED LOW LEVELS OF
INFECTIOUSNESS OF CHILDREN.
AGAIN, I’M NOT DISCOURAGING
ANYONE FROM WEARING A MASK.
BUT THE WORLD IS FULL OF EXPERTS
WHO GOT BIG ISSUES WRONG, ISN’T
IT?
BEFORE AMERICANS ARE FORCED TO
ACCEPT NEW RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR
FREEDOM OR EVEN BE SHAMED OR
BEATEN UP FOR NOT COMPLYING WITH
THESE MANDATES, SHOULDN’T STATE
LEGISLATURES HOLD HEARINGS AND
DISCUSS THE FINDINGS THAT I JUST
BROUGHT YOU TONIGHT?
THEN THEY SHOULD PASS ACTUAL
LAWS ABOUT MASTS, SOCIAL
DISTANCING, LIVE IT THAT CAN
WITHSTAND JUDICIAL SCRUTINY.
WE MUST INSIST ON ALL OF THIS,
DEMAND TO SEE ALL OF THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THE LOCKED DOWN, SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THE MASK.
OTHERWISE, DON’T BE SURPRISED IF